this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
merry christmas to you america
merry christmas well it's nice to hear
those two words that's good that's why
it should be yeah i like that i noticed
you didn't say happy holidays
well that's me because
my political correct stuff's kind of way
low on the thing so open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five ken coleman is uh all about the ken
coleman show and what he does there of
course is help you with your career and
your jobs and making decisions on the
move and this is a season when a lot of
people reevaluate coming into the new
year heading that direction so you got
questions on your mind about the great
resignation about jobs or careers or
whatever ken's here to help and we're
here to help about life and money and in
any part of it we'll just talk to you
it's what we do phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
colin is in dallas texas hey colin how
are you
rave i am better than i deserve how you
doing just the same sir how can i help
wonderful uh well first off it is an
honor to speak to both you and ken
really big fans
discovered you about a year ago and
unfortunately got into elite a little
too late
on that and so my wife and i were in
baby step two really our lease is the
only thing that's really keeping us
outside of our mortgage from being debt
free so i had a question
the
buy out on this lease
is about 27 000
and we could actually the kelly blue
book value of the car
is close to about 40.
and so my question for you is perhaps
should we actually
take out a loan
do the payoff of this car and then turn
around and sell it and then buy it take
that profit and put it toward a cash car
uh what's your household income
uh so it's roughly about 85 90 000 okay
so the car is really probably with if
you own another vehicle or two or a
lawnmower or anything you have too much
tied up in car
so the car isn't it's too expensive a
purchase you got to move it right
yeah okay
so don't you just sell it
well we're
well so yeah so that's so it's a lease
right now i know so that's what we're
just saying should we
should we you can sell it buy it out it
works exactly the same way you can go
get a loan if you want to but it works
exactly the same way with a fleece as it
does with just paying off a car there's
a car loan if you had a 27 000 loan on
the car and you sold it for 40 um
the buyer would give you a check
and um you would have to take it to the
bank and it would take a couple of weeks
for the title to come in because the
bank stored has stored the title in
another city
and so you would give the buyer in most
states now i don't i don't know how it
works in texas but in most states you
give the buyer a bill of sale the keys
and the car and they drive off and the
title will come a few weeks later when
you get the title after you paid the car
off
okay
same same exact thing here you're just
going to pay the car off you're going to
send them a check for 27 thousand
dollars purchase and pay the car off
simultaneously and they're going to send
you a title
okay
so you're saying to
find a buyer first for the car the buyer
has to be willing to buy a car that has
a lien against it
you got it like it does pretend you had
a 27 000 loan which is what you're
talking about doing over at the bank
anyway
right if you want to go to the bank and
the bank's not going to charge you any
fees and just get a loan and pay it off
that'll get the title in your hometown
and you could go to the bank with the
buyer if it's sitting at a branch or
something
right if you're dealing with a local
bank that you have connection with if
the title's sitting at your branch
manager's desk and you run over there
with the buyer you can do the
transaction all in one fell swoop that
makes a buyer much more comfortable
typically
got it okay but if you're dealing with a
bank that's going to hold the title out
of town
it's not much different than where you
are today
okay now you also check with a car
dealer friend of yours locally and find
out how it's done in texas but that's
how it's done in most states
um some states are wacky on everything
and it's worth checking on but um you
know that's the big thing the good news
is you're going to get a car that you
pay 13 000 cash for and you're not gonna
have any debt anymore when the smoke
clears that's the bottom line yeah yeah
and i the only thing i'd add to that is
dealers are looking for cars they're
advertising everywhere we'll buy your
car we'll buy your car and a dealer
maybe where he got it from probably buy
it back for that kind of money and take
care of all that if you can get a 40 on
a trade in yeah
i don't know what the sales tax rate is
in texas but in tennessee we've got a
pretty we have no income tax but we have
pretty healthy sales tax and so if you
were to do a trade and walk out of a
dealer with a 13 000 car paid for and
let the dealer handle all this
transaction
now you don't want to take a ten
thousand dollar discount because it's a
dealer okay but if you can get a good
buy out of a dealer on the purchase car
and on the sale of your car uh you might
save uh sales tax on the whole
transaction
you would in tennessee yeah so um yeah
that's so that's the only reason i say
that it's just it's just bustling crazy
out there right now it's crazy
traditional history you'd take a you
take a hit on that yeah but now i'd kick
the tires on it because you know
yeah there there it is folks walked
right into that yeah you did you just
underhand pitch man
well that was a harmless one thankfully
you know what i mean it's like i didn't
couldn't get any trouble with that one
but it could work out to where it's an
easier transaction is the point might be
much easier yeah there you go tony is
with us tony is in kansas city hi tony
how are you
better than i deserve dave
good how can i know
so we were in baby steps four five and
six and my husband got an opportunity to
move to a different state and so we made
it um to be close to the family
and the housing market here is double
where we were at no until
no it's not
there's not a place that's half of
kansas city in the united states
okay we lived in a smaller area in
illinois and a good site's house was 200
250 000. we're moving here um and
they're closer to lots of 250 000
there's lots of 250 000 houses in kansas
city
okay but we want to be in a good school
district
okay that's not double that's i want to
live in a better neighborhood
okay
yeah okay so
our question is we are completely
debt-free moved into an apartment um
that was 25 of our take-home but we're
looking at do we live in the apartment
longer than five years to get in the
neighborhood we want to or
do you know
um
more than 25 percent of our income or 30
or more
or you look in a different neighborhood
then we're looking at at least an hour
commute for my husband you know what
you got house fever girl and you picked
out a house and you're trying to
convince me to let you do something
stupid i'm not gonna play your game
okay don't do it you you got house
figures dripping off of you go take a
cold shower and drive it around in a
different neighborhood than the one
you've been driving around in
you're trying to box me in the corner
with like two stupid decisions and i
have to choose between them i'm not
gonna do that to you if you won't go do
it it's not gonna be on me it's not
gonna because dave ramsey said do it
but you know i think there's another
house in kansas city for you darling
it's the third option c none of the
above
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
and coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825.5225.
tristan is with us in davenport iowa hi
tristan how are you
uh better than
i should be
how about you better than i should be
what's up
uh well long story short i'm supposed to
be moving to the apartments up near the
moline western illinois university
facility
for engineering and uh well i'm not
going to have an income on there and
they want triple to
rent an income or a upfront payment
fined by me can't do a student loan so
thank goodness for that
and my family and i are having a little
dispute about this i'm thinking
a
gap year to save up as much money as i
can and
chunk it out like
would be
best in my head
and they're going
let's
re-refinance the home and pay for it
that way
what would you recommend here
wow
uh a different apartment
i have to go to an apartment there's no
dorms up there and it's 100 miles from
the nearest campus no a different one
i have okay so western illinois
university has an engineering campus
and the engineering campus does not have
dorms i got that
but the apartment that you have
presented
has terms that you cannot do
so far
a very different apartment
there's one apartment in the entire town
no there's several and most of them have
the exact same no no no no no no
no
no
you went to one
no i've called 10
i have records
okay
uh
i'm calling bull but anyway the um
well let's play it out so you didn't say
all of them okay how many how many how
many apartment complexes are in the
entire area you've done enough there's a
rich old lady with a garage
old lady with a garage outback that you
could rent her garage
apartment for nothing and she'll work
with you and oh by the way you need to
work while you're in school i don't know
what this crap is you can't work
fair enough
and pay for the apartment i mean
it's just you all you do is cover the
rent living over a garage
has got to be way less than all the
fancy apartments with all the stuff
there's a way to do this
but you haven't exhausted all of your
options dave's absolutely right about
that and you have to exhaust all your
options
i i know you're right
i've only got
five weeks to figure it out though
well you ain't got nothing else to do
you should be able to do this in 48
hours i could run it you could rent
something if you just get after it this
thing called the interweb you get out
there on that thing and you know thanks
to al gore you could find out a lot of
information or just you know hey if
listen if i paid you a hundred thousand
dollars to go solve this problem without
borrowing money
you could figure it out because you're a
sharp dude you're getting ready to go
into an engineer right
fair enough so here's the thing let me
tell you what here's what you're bumping
up against just two problems and i want
to help you with those because it's
going to help you with a whole bunch of
things
number one is
if you will draw a line in the sand in
your life that says i don't borrow money
i have to figure out a way to do this
without borrowing money
suddenly other options will come out
because borrowing money is always the
easiest way to do almost anything
short term
but it destroys the long term
but i mean if you want to get a car it's
easier to go borrow money and walk off a
lot with a car it's harder than working
and saving up money to get a car if you
want to
do anything fill in the blank borrowed
money is always the easiest upfront and
the hardest long term because you get to
pay back payments with interest and it
destroys and screws up your life and you
look back later and kick your own butt
because it didn't force you
to
seek out other creative alternatives to
the problem the second thing you don't
want to do
is you don't want to deal in absolutes
and fatalist thinking which is what
ken's pointing out and that that concept
is this when making decisions if the
only options on the table are dumb ones
you need more options
not not start rationalizing and
declaring in your mind well this is in
freaking nowhere near nothing and
there's only 10 apartments and i called
all 10 of them and so that's it case
closed i'm screwed
and so now i have to decide which stupid
thing i'm going to do of the two stupid
options and i will throw one other thing
to add to that list tristan this is
really important you've got family
that is recommending to you debt because
that's what everybody else does because
they think it's going to pay off and
they think it's normal and i think
there's two things you're going to have
to realize you have to do in this moment
you wanted us to tell you that you
shouldn't do debt and you know you
shouldn't do debt so you're going to
have to deal with
either disappointing your family or
resenting your family or finding a whole
different way of doing it and them not
understanding and that's okay that's
what i'm saying he has to disappoint
them well it's not like like he
no no what about shot the next door
neighbors no no no no no no no no i'm
talking about the pressure he's feeling
yeah he just went and got an apartment
that's all he did yeah when family puts
pressure on us here's what we have to do
we do what's right and when what's right
may disappoint them and i don't mean
they don't or confuse them yeah i'm just
getting the point i'm making is you will
resent them if you do something that you
know is wrong exactly and so i always
want to choose disappointing somebody
versus resenting them you know why i
think you've got them i think you're
you're obviously bright because you
don't get into engineering school if
you're stupid okay
and um
you know you've got a an incredibly
bright future and a gap year is not just
not necessary
i mean figure out a way to find some
place to live get a get get somebody
else that's got an apartment already
that's a two bedroom and become their
roommate i don't know what it is
but this idea that you have to come up
front with money or take a gap year is
the only two possible options
um it's just not accurate tristan
it's just not accurate okay ken uh
that's two for two okay we gotta stop a
minute all right
so when i'm teaching leadership to entre
leaders people running businesses
i teach them the same situation it's
simple decision making framework okay
human beings
if we're not careful
um
we can
pick out something that we want to do
and we can't figure out a way to do the
thing
um and that's both of these last two
callers um
uh we can't figure out a way to do the
thing that it's in front of us and and
so we box ourselves into a corner
without enough options when you're
making decisions when you're making
decisions
you need every possible option on the
table until a good one sticks its head
up yeah
and when you're looking at things and
you're saying
i've got a bad idea or another bad idea
and i have to choose between the two bad
ideas
what's happening is you have
you know you've convinced yourself that
you have to do one of them and you're
trying to figure out a way to justify oh
well it's it was the least of all evils
that's right and that's just not good
paradigm that's just not good critical
thinking skills so what amounts to is
you've got to be another way there's got
to be another way there's got to be
another way there's got to be another
way and you just keep asking that
question until you figure out what that
other way is and that's when you find
the rich old lady with the apartment
with the garage apartment out back and
she thinks you're a cute young college
student and you will clean her gutters
for her that's right and you will mow
her grass and you might end up with free
rent and a new friend
and you might end up with all kinds of
things you know increase quality
relationships in your life everything
else
versus um
i've got corporate
apartments over here so i hear this all
the time for instance with that's why
i'm calling bs on his apartment thing uh
because you know we've had different
empty personalities anthony o'neil when
he was here and others sit and call
apartment complexes and they said do you
have to have a fico score do you have to
have a fico score you have to have a
fico score and nine out of ten of them
say no
but people tell me all the time you
can't run an apartment without a fico
score because they called and talked to
the one they wanted to rent right
and so they now i got to go get a credit
card because the one i wanted to rent
and so now you're coming i got two
stupid things
yeah and one and they're boxing me in
more options you need more options
here's the key you make the right
decision the big decision then you
manage
against that decision so i'm not going
to go into debt while i go to school i'm
not going to go in debt to live so
that's the decision now i go and i
manage against that decision
that's the key and i'm not taking a gap
here
so is it am i living in a tent am i
living in my car that's right am i
living in a rich old ladies apartment am
i getting a roommate have i gone up
there and spent two weeks looking for
properties because this is a problem i
got to solve
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
getting coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the debt free stage in
the lobby of ramsey solutions manuel and
zabina are with us hey guys welcome to
ramsey thank you hello good to have you
now where do you guys live uh germany
all right well welcome to nashville so
this may be our first in-person
international debt free screening oh oh
really
you're german yeah yes and you live in
germany you're not americans living in
germany okay wow so how did you find us
yeah that's actually funny um about 10
years ago someone on a disney message
board mentioned being uh debt free and
being on the day for mz plan and uh
going to disney completely um yeah with
cash that's cool
and that peaked your interest and you
decided debt-free is a good idea yeah a
little bit but it took me a while to get
on board yes later all right so how much
have you paid off we paid of 119 000
very good and how long did that take you
23 months good for you and your range of
income during that time we started at
about 180 and we ended at 2 30. good
what do you guys do for a living uh i'm
an actuary
i'm electrical engineer ah very good
okay cool well thanks for doing all the
conversion to dollars so our audience
will have a clue and me will have a clue
what we're talking about because i just
spent half my time in the math but
very good so what kind of debt was the
119 000
um it was two cars and
home remodeling ah okay all right so you
found us on a disney message board but
somewhere along two years ago
something happened and you decided uh
we're doing this ramsey stuff what
happened
yeah so back then um i was doing our
finances by myself um and i was always
stressed out because for some reason
there was just never any money left
despite me knowing in my head we made a
lot of money
and then in the spring of 19 our golden
retriever puppy got meningitis
and so on top of worrying if our dog was
going to make it i was also stressing
out about how we were going to pay for
the treatment and that was kind of my
i've had it moment and i went online and
i found your website and i remembered
the name from years back and then um
yeah about the total money makeover read
it and was completely on board
and um yeah then i talked to him and he
was like
um i'm the spender so he was just not
convinced that i was really going to do
it but
yeah
not necessarily of the system but of the
person doing it
so yeah and then he said well let's just
try it and then you saw how committed i
was and then like a couple months later
we were on board and it was time to go
game on yeah okay and both of you join
hands and are working on it together and
came on and 119 000 knocks out in 23
months magical isn't it yeah well yeah
way to go you guys so you've really
sacrificed i mean you really poured into
this did you sell anything big
no just little things on ebay but yeah
most of it was just
what do you say um beans and rice rice
meats yeah right yeah what's the german
version of that
um
is there well literally translated it's
uh boone and rice
but that's not a german name
cheap german oh potatoes potatoes
kraut and potatoes maybe yeah well
something like that yeah
that's awesome sounds pretty good it
actually does better than rice and beans
i think
possibly yeah way to go guys
congratulations and you just had to make
a trip all the way to nashville to do
this oh yeah i wanted to come here uh
from the beginning anyway this was an
excuse
yeah no i wanted to do the debt-free
scream all along but we're also here um
because a friend of ours is getting
married at disney uh next sunday so
we're gonna go to orlando after heading
down to florida that feels uh poetic
you hear about dave ramsey uh as you you
know you're on a message board on a
cruise message and now you're going to
do your debt free scream and go ahead
and celebrate at disney yes that's
incredible exactly that's that's that's
true
i like that that's really great very i'm
a big disney fan so that worked okay
so
here in the states we just wanted to
have a huge car oh so we got an f-150
for the winter
of course massive
way to go oh we are german so we kind of
love cars yeah yeah well we know how to
buy car so
so what kind of cars have you got at
home
yeah we have two bmws of course and and
those were the dead and yeah that was
our biggest fight if we were gonna sell
one of them i wanted to sell it because
i was all in it was like yeah she was
more than i was yeah well i mean 23
months you got them done yeah that's
perfect yeah good and they're great cars
so well done i love it this is so fun
okay so
i've had uh a limited exposure to german
culture uh been there a couple times
visiting but um
uh the the
the stereotype is the best way of saying
is positive on money that germans are
very frugal
in general is that true
yeah um
there's definitely unless they go to buy
bmw but yeah exactly that that's the
thing um there's i don't think there's
big credit card debt issues or anything
but people do go into that for cars
but yeah i felt a bit weird um having
that much debt and realizing i had that
much debt and i think i felt a bit of
shame because i do think most germans
don't go into debt as much
they do
have mortgages so that's completely
normal and and accept it but anything
else yeah that's very much canadians
kind of have that same thing except
they're very almost uh
until this generation
a mortgage in canada was just unheard of
and uh they've they've picked up the
mortgage thing and running with it but
canadians are that way too in general i
mean but again there's massive numbers
of both that do dumb things with money
just like there is in america so and i'm
sure there's there's actually a lot of
germans who are in debt but we just
don't talk about it as much
i don't hear either they just wear it
yeah ah good for you guys i'm so proud
of you congratulations and thank you for
making a trip to nashville to share this
with us we've got a copy of the brand
new book baby steps millionaires that
will come out in january but we're going
to give you guys an advanced copy today
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and pay it
forward to someone maybe that couple
getting married maybe they can get
started on that you never know so uh
very very cool stuff congratulations now
what do you tell people that the key to
getting out of debt is you paid off 119
000 in 23 months and very little of it
was due to selling things right but
being a discipline
yeah that's the german version of it
budgeting definitely um and and like
being on the same page and then just um
knowing what that you wanted like you
really have to want it otherwise you're
not going to stick with it because you
had to say no like a lot
yeah what was the hardest thing that you
had to say no to
uh vacations
but then covet help with that
[Laughter]
someone else said no for you yeah
i like it okay
cool well have a good time while you're
here in america and in orlando you'll
have a blast down there as well we're so
proud of y'all
very very well done congratulations good
stuff
all right manuel and zabina and i
probably destroyed that but that's the
best i can do at it
119 000 paid off in 23 months making 180
to 230 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
we are that free
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the interesting thing
the law of gravity works in every
culture yeah it's true the truth yeah
works in every culture when you know
what the truth is and you function in
that it works um developing countries
countries that are you know
very sophisticated uh it turns out the
truth works in all of them and this idea
of oh i woke up and i'm going to get on
the same page with my husband and we're
going to get out of debt and we're going
to sacrifice we're going to say no to
things and now we're free yeah yeah it's
it's fascinating to see and i love
little nuances to the story first of all
i got to say i love hearing the
international countdown i hope that
catches on i hope people from all around
the globe decide to come here we'd love
to treat you with great southern
hospitality and hear your story but one
of the things i think is great is is for
those the whole tribe that's listening
right now when you just go on a disney
message board
and you're there to book a cruise but
you say you know what because of this
ramsay solutions dave ramsey guy we were
able to pay cash for our cruise and you
just put it out there having no idea the
impact that it had i just love that part
of the story yeah this stuff still works
and share it don't be ashamed there's
someone this is a great story one and
cousin wanted someone else to win
and who knew they were going to reach
all the way across the atlantic that's
that's the butterfly effect really cool
yeah that's powerful that's a good point
it's a very good point very very good
point
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we all know the story of the
tortoise and the hare of course is one
of my favorites because the slow and
steady tortoise wins the race every time
but we often overlook the reason for the
hare's downfall he didn't lose because
he was slow
he lost because he took a nap
he chose to put off what he knew he
should do in favor of what he wanted to
do for all you tortoises out there we
know how hard it is to keep pushing
fighting hacking away at your debt
especially when you see all the hairs
around you quitting their jobs
deferring their student loan payments
financing vacations and cars they can't
afford wouldn't it be great to get a
boost this time of year what about our
ramsey christmas cash giveaway this year
we're giving away
up to 5 000
and you can enter to win at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway
no purchase is necessary and you can
enter every day to increase your chances
of winning
for an extra dose of motivation just in
time for the new year our team is
featuring a new deal every day
so today only when you buy the total
money makeover book for 10 bucks you'll
also get know yourself know your money
gift card
for free
make 2020 your best wealth building year
yet shop our one day deal at our online
store at
ramseysolutions.com andy is in stockton
california hi andy welcome to the ramsey
show
mr ramsey and mr coleman great and what
an honor to speak to you guys um my wife
and i are wanting to come to you for
some wisdom today
um so
uh my wife and i um want to know if we
should pay off our house today
and use it as a rental property and wait
till the uh the housing market cools off
or should we sell our house and apply
the proceeds to a newer bigger house
since we have a month old son and
possibly uh adding another
little one to our family soon
okay i'm i'm a little bit confused on
the details so you own a house today you
have the money to pay it off today
correct so what do you owe on the house
uh 120 and you have how much in the bank
120 with a 20 000 emergency fund on top
of that okay
you have 100 you have exactly the amount
you need without touching your emergency
fund to pay off your house and your
house is worth what
uh
conservative estimates are anywhere from
375 to 400. okay and the house you want
to buy is how much
uh about
600 to 650 000
okay and what do you guys make a year
158
okay
so when would you buy the two different
times you in either case you're going to
sell the current home that you're in
whether you sell it now and buy later or
buy now is that your question
well correct so the idea would be
whether or not um
my wife and i are kind of in the
discussion phase of whether or not we
should pay off because this house that
we're currently living in is a house
that i bought before yeah but if you if
you you don't have the money to pay cash
for the other house so you can't keep
this house
okay
it's got to go because you're you're of
essentially borrowing on your new home
to keep to buy a rental
okay that's what i thought you were
going to say i just was i just wanted to
make sure that um
i had a feeling you were going to say
that okay so that was the question okay
i misunderstood the question okay yeah
if that's the question that's easy no we
don't borrow on our current residence to
buy a rental
and in essence by by keeping a paid for
home
and then going borrowing that much more
four hundred thousand dollars more in
debt on your new home uh it says if you
borrowed 400 or
400 thousand dollars to buy that rental
and no i would not do that
so
just reverse engineer it right yeah yeah
and and again i think here here again i
mean they with the income they've got
the money they got in the bank they can
certainly go up to a 600 house but six
hundred thousand dollar house but
only one eight month old i don't know
okay to move up to that i mean you got a
200 000 mortgage making 158 and he's
young he's going to pay it off you know
put on 10-year mortgage yeah knock it
out
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from joe in california my family and i
are relocating to knoxville tennessee
and i'm finding it hard to secure
employment since we still live out of
state we're debt-free except our current
mortgage when our home sells will have
330 000 in addition to 40 000 in cash
already saved for the move i'm a skilled
telecommunications tech and i don't
anticipate finding a job once we arrive
as my job types seem to be in high
demand in that area we would live off of
our savings until i find a job can we
move as soon as our house sells and
worry about finding a job after we get
there i would not do that uh seems to be
some some irony in this question if it's
in high demand
and you're skilled i think this is a
couple of trips
use some vacation time beforehand you
know you've got the cash
i would not live off of it once i moved
there i would delay uh the move until i
had something waiting for me because i
just don't think it's going to be that
difficult for you
to move into knoxville tennessee as a
skilled telecommunications tech and get
a gig uh you may have to you have to go
there several times we have to make
several trips make some great
connections ahead of time go in and and
do interviews and and find something
you've got some relationships in that
area i just think this is a false
narrative so i would not uh move as soon
as the house sells uh without a job
because i don't think it's necessary but
you do have the savings so i don't think
it's a bad decision yeah it is it's a
bad decision all right let's don't do it
don't
well here's what's gonna happen joe
you're gonna move over there and then
you're gonna screw around for six or
eight weeks goofing off blow through too
much and say i was looking for a job no
you weren't you know but if you go get a
job first you go to work when you move
that's right that's what'll happen
that's just human nature and you'll use
was i didn't look good
and you're gonna have all this crap in
your head all these reasons why you
didn't go to work but if you got a job
and you start two weeks after you move
you know exactly when your start time is
you're hired your butt will be in gear
you'll go be going to work
and that's what you need to do you need
to drive your butt over there and get
you a job lined up and then put your
house on the market it'll sell in 20
minutes and then you make your move it's
very easy to do yeah but don't don't go
over there i'm gonna work it out it'll
all work out you know it's not like you
know that's how people you know why this
is sometimes people end up waiting
tables it doesn't want to wait till
that's right well and so it's not
convenient from california to knoxville
back and forth to be in person but
you've got 40 000 bucks in a bank
there's a thing called a jet airplane
just get on one that's right let's get
on one there's direct flights into
nashville's beautiful two and a half
hour drive over to knoxville and
probably a direct la flight into
knoxville i don't know you're not the
only person in california coming to
tennessee oh my god i'm seeing those
plates everywhere there may be more
californians here than tennesseans by
the end of the year oh it's getting
scary
y'all don't california or tennessee now
that's the truth open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money so ken the beauty of a
job market like this is that
um i mean you talk about this in
paycheck to purpose your best-selling
book the one we just did but
is this market is so hot if you will
apply some basic principles
you can land something in 20 minutes
nowadays i mean it's
it you know it really is a buyer's
market for if you're looking for a job
yeah you're going to have to own the
fact that yes i got to put myself out
there but if you use different tools and
that is relationships relationships
relationships get yourself out there
companies are in a situation right now
dave here's the last two job numbers
august and september 4.3 million left in
august change jobs 4.
4 in september that's nearly 9 million
people have changed locations it is a
game of musical chairs out there right
now and companies are paying more
they're willing to hire you all you've
got to do is put yourself out there and
say hey i've got the experience i've got
the skill and i've got the desire to be
here you're going to be an extremely
attractive candidate and so the the kind
of the psychology around the job search
i mean you have to flip the rock over
for something well you have to but
that's the point is most people don't
want to do that but if you're willing to
do it now is going to be the best payoff
for that
put the work in do what we teach in the
book from paycheck to purpose the ken
coleman show website kencoleman.com
we've got free tools tools that you can
pay for and let me tell you something
now is the time to get it it's not going
to stay this way yeah it's like it's
like a seller's market on a house that's
right i mean you know you just you
stinking houses are going crazy
and it's a great time to sell a horrible
time to buy yeah it's a great time to
look for a job horrible time to be
hiring yes you know that's the process
and so we've got an advantage here
because we've got an unusually awesome
culture and people want to work here
but a lot of companies are struggling
with that because they're not that
appealing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america open phones
at triple eight eight two five five
two ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money and
with ken here your career
scott is with us to start off this hour
hey scott welcome to the ramsay show hi
dave thank you for having me on sure
what's up
um so i have a question about a 529 plan
for my
child
putting money into that or maxing out my
roth iras and retirements instead
because
i'll be
around age 62
when he's 18 going to college so
my thought is that i could just
cash flow my retirement instead of doing
the 529 plan i didn't know if there's
any advantages or disadvantages that i'm
not thinking of
uh let me back up are you out of debt
yes
house and everything
correct way to go dude congratulations
how much is in your retirement account
uh right now i have about
400 000 oh
what's your paid for house worth
uh around 200 good for you you're doing
great man
well done thank you well done
um
okay so
it almost is a matter of
philosophy of life versus
it's not a big deal mathematically uh a
529 gross tax-free roth ira goes
tax-free
all right and so if money gets trapped
in the 529 and isn't used it wouldn't be
trapped in the roth ira and so it would
have been good to have it over there
however
you can do both
since you have no payments at all
i don't know why you couldn't max out
your roth iras and
do some 529. why can't you do both
uh well i am well a backup i guess so
i'm doing maxing out my roth ira and
maxing out
my 457 right and do his college what do
you make what's your household income
around eighty thousand oh i think starts
getting pinchy okay
all right uh
yeah
i if the way i answer questions here
scott is what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes okay
you're gonna be a millionaire when this
kid goes to school times a bunch
probably two or three million so you're
gonna be fine the kid's going to school
that's not in question you're going to
have the money and you're going to the
money to retire that's not in question
so what would i do i
was in a similar situation
um
i guess at your age and i chose to do
some in the kids college fund
but i didn't over fund it
and so even if you said okay i'm going
to take
i'm going to split the idea on this i'm
going to take 50 out of my money and pay
for college and i'm going to put 50 of
what i think the college is going to be
into the 529
and so then so the 529 is not enough
the way i'm talking about funding it
you've not funded it well enough to pay
for college but you're gonna have
millions of dollars over here and you'll
be 62 and you can access it in your roth
right
right okay yeah and
there there's something about saying
kids college
and then i don't have any money saved
for kids college directly with a label
on it that that just feels wrong down
inside
and so i had kids college funds
um in addition to building wealth and
maxing out retirement when i was your
age
um
dealing with a little bit more income
than you were than you're dealing with
at that time
but uh but i i did all that so yeah i'm
not if i have to choose i'm going to
back off a little and say i'm going to
put
i don't know 500 bucks a month 6 000 a
year into a 529 or
even three thousand dollars a year even
even 250 a month and none of that really
changes the equation but there's
something about
the groove in your brain and the
conversations around your kitchen table
this your college fund is your college
fund
versus uh gotcha college covered it's
over here in my retirement there's
something that changes in the in the
household spirit what is that
specifically
it's it's an it's i'm an old salesman i
guess and it's the assumptive clothes
yeah kind of this is what i always told
my kids they have a college fund that's
your college fund that's your college
fund this college which assumes your
butt's going to college oh yeah that's
what i thought right that's what i
thought you were getting at yeah there's
something in there with that instead of
like oh you got lots of options because
there's money and whatever you want to
do you know and it was just like i i
believe in a four-year education i like
education i think it's a good thing i
don't think it's necessary to win and i
think it's overpriced right now
in most places and i think a lot of
people study stupid stuff during that
four years they need to stop doing that
but uh but i i'm not willing to go all
higher education is not worth it like
some people are saying that's bull
you make more in some cases being a
welder
oh you make more in some cases being
diesel mechanic yeah than you can
getting a degree in left-handed puppetry
yeah you know and so yeah i follow the
middle on that as you know but i but
it's based on reality that's because the
best player the only way there's the
only way you go get a four-year degree
is if you're studying something that's
usable yep i'm a utilitarian pragmatic
person in that regard so but but uh but
i i
you know my youngest is 30 so it was a
different world when i started saving
for their college that's correct but in
this world today what would i do i would
have something
if you'd asked me
four years ago i would have said fully
fund college
so i have shifted right but as you've
pointed out accurately and i'm i can
attest to this is what i'm seeing and
reading every day and talking to callers
on the phone on the ken coleman show
look the fact of the matter is that 529
can go towards certifications and other
non-four-year degree things that are
just as valuable yeah for the kids i
want to go get some you know maxed out
on your microsoft uh search so you're
going to technology yeah you can go that
route this is your future fund you know
it's it doesn't have to be traditional
college however 529 pays for a lot of
qualifications and it is a good
expectation to put out there i think
that's great yeah and it's just i
there's something
that says in our fam you know how many
people have you ever talked to that say
um
uh my mom was a teacher so our family
valued education yeah
kind of a question and so i had to go i
felt like i needed to get an education
and that has served that that mentality
serves you well versus you don't need to
go to school you just be one of them
stuck up college boys you know if you
grew up in that house right you know
then you got a you have a different view
on the power of knowledge that's right
and knowledge is powerful it is it is it
opens doors it causes your brain to
reshape and see things you've never seen
before and do things you've never done
before yes and uh what got you there
won't get you here
what got you here won't get you there or
however you say it if you had good
knowledge you could say that correctly
but you know
that's right
you're setting an expectation that in
order to do something you're gonna have
to learn something and you're gonna have
to get some experience and you need a
plan for this it's really what you're
great at it's really i think what you're
really known for you're a legend when it
comes to when a plan
works
it changes the game and planning
planning planning planning planning and
that's what you're putting a seat in the
minds of their kids there's a plan
you're putting a groove in your brain
this is the way things are yeah and uh
you need to do it to yourself you trick
yourself to trick yourself into winning
habits yeah that's right james clear's
book atomic habits i mean same thing
right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
ken is one of the few people that knows
that i have a phd
in d-u-m-b
i have done stupid with zeros on the end
i know what it looks like i'm so dumb i
had to become a millionaire twice
um which proves that it can be done
i could do it twice if you surely you
can do it once and i can show you
exactly how
we do this with the baby steps we've
shown people how to become millionaires
we've been teaching this stuff for 30
years and the number of people that show
up out in the lobby that i meet that are
millionaires now because they followed
the baby steps they've been doing it
five 10 15 years 20 years in some cases
and uh you know it wasn't get rich quick
and it was slow and steady and it wasn't
sexy and sometimes their family made fun
of them but now they're millionaires we
call them baby steps millionaires
and i i started becoming concerned that
people didn't believe they could do it
and our thing around here is hope
your thing is hope on getting a job in a
career that has purpose our thing on
hope is you know not only do you get it
can you get out of debt and you should
but the only reason to do that is so
that you can become wealthy so that you
can change your family tree and so that
you can be outrageously generous there's
also that
and hope is a big deal so when people
start beco losing their hope or other
people start trying to steal your hope
with a
negative narrative
then it's our job around here to punch
that thing in the face and so i haven't
done a book in eight years but i decided
to do one it's called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
and i systematically go through and show
you how to do it and i defeat all the
arguments that you can't do it
so after you read this book there's no
freaking excuses
that's simple
is it some stuff dave ramsey said before
of course i'm a one-trick pony i only
know how to do one thing
so of course you're gonna hear stuff you
heard before no question about it and
but if you want to pre-order this book
it's 20 it comes out in january and
we're going to throw in about uh over
100 and some odd dollars worth of items
with it the baby steps millionaire audio
book and ebook the legacy journey audio
book and ebook the baby steps
millionaire live stream in january a
free filing with ramsey smart tax for
your federal income tax
and a ramsey plus free trial for 30 days
to get into financial peace university
get started on your baby steps with your
every with your every dollar budgeting
app the whole thing all goes together
and you get you know we're gonna ship
you what we can right now and the rest
of it will come to you in january when
the book comes out all twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com eric is in san
antonio hey eric what's up in your world
not too much work and i'm i'm late to a
meeting hope it doesn't cost me my job
that would be sad wouldn't it call you
guys
and have that happen well if it happened
let ken coleman know he'll help you get
enough i'll get you a better one that
pays you more anyway so don't sweat it
listen i listen to you guys driving home
and there's so much work around here i
can't believe anybody can't find a job
hey
quick question i'm 55 my wife is 42 i'm
retired military
i've been very bad about saving money up
until the last 10 years and i've been
trying to play catch up i'm saving a lot
now well what i i feel is a lot
uh i have a house in oklahoma
that's paid for
i'm on a 15-year mortgage here
uh oh 200 000 maybe 198
and i'm trying to decide do i sell that
house now
and pay as much as i can it's only worth
about 130 i might have said that or do i
wait till i'm ready to retire because i
got four kids two of them are pretty
young and i want my house paid for
before i kick the bucket you know i mean
that needs to be off the plate
it's pretty simple for me
okay if you had
the house in oklahoma's worth 130 000
bucks so what you said
yes sir if you had 130 000 pile in the
middle of your table and you did not own
a house in oklahoma
benjamin's looking at you in the face
would you pay it down on your house
or would you go buy a rental property in
oklahoma that's an easy answer
yeah yeah that's an easy answer selling
that's easy
okay all right well that was my main
question yeah that's why because all the
reasons that you would sell it i mean
all the reasons you wouldn't go buy it
again is why you sell it you're a
landlord in oklahoma by default
not by plan
and so time to undo the default
and uh it's just convenience is the only
reason you own it it's not even
convenient it's freaking in oklahoma
so yeah sell it sell it i love rental
properties paid for it's a wonderful
thing to have and i'd like like for you
to have some of that someday as part of
your portfolio if you want to but in
your case i'm getting my house paid off
and what's he and you know this we hear
this day in and day out on the show when
he does that and takes takes a big chunk
130 000 on that house it is going to
fast forward everything because the
momentum he's going to feel i mean you
talk about a great high going towards a
big long-term goal i think he pays it
off faster than he could possibly
imagine with that one big chunk that
gets him started yeah i mean when you
can see oh
how quickly you can pay it off after
it's gone i mean you know this
intellectually but it's weird
emotionally that when you're actually
going wait a minute i've only have that
left
and you reach over and you run you run
to the finish line even though you're
already out of breath that's right you
know it's pretty amazing yeah pretty
amazing bill is with us in rochester new
york hi bill welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and ken how's it going better
than i deserve what's up
well i i'm 26 almost 27 years old
i've got a brand new house that we
purchased in december of last year
um through my work i've been fortunate
to to do pretty well in my profession
where i've got a significant amount of
commission bonuses and other items that
are being paid out to me over the course
of this next year um so my question
being we're in a position where we can
completely pay off our mortgage by
december 1st of 2022. awesome um
yeah
yeah so uh really just trying to i've
kind of heard conflicting opinions from
from everybody that i've talked in this
question so figured i'd come right to
the top
um whether or not i should be putting at
all and paying off the mortgage or if i
should be looking to take that money and
invest it into other avenues
well
the position i answer that from
is this position
30 years
of teaching people
how to become wealthy
okay
and all of the evidence that i have in
front of me including the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america done by ramsey research in
detail airtight research
all of the evidence says
the fastest way to become wealthy is to
become debt free and free up your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income
here's what
happens it's hard to breathe in right
now but this time next year you're going
to breathe it in
when you don't have a payment in the
world
you analyze your
career track differently
you make different decisions
on vacations
you make different decisions on a car
purchase
you make different decisions on
generosity
and all of those things
increase the speed at which you build
wealth i was going to say probability
but if the probabilities is 100
but the speed at which you build wealth
because there's something inside your
soul that relaxes
when you walk out in the backyard at
christmas next year
and the grass is yours because you paid
it off and take off your shoes even if
it's cold
you're gonna feel
different
and that's an intangible that ends up
reflecting in the mathematics long term
does that make sense to you
yep yeah no exactly and uh in other
words you know the number of people that
panicked during the pandemic
because they had a big honking house
payment
and freaked out and did stupid butt
stuff or took a job they hated or made a
bad decision because they had to make a
payment
so you really can't put a mathematical
figure too stupid
but the panic caused people to be stupid
and i've been i've panicked and been
stupid right so i know how it feels i'm
not making fun of somebody but the
difference in that versus the guy who's
sitting there the gals who's sitting
there with a paid for home
and can they get ready to do a a job
change yeah
and they make a different they they look
different in the interview
oh well you walk into an you carry your
shoulders different in the interview
when you don't have a house payment yes
but even before that you actually look
at things that you're afraid to look at
when you got a bunch of debt you see
opportunity to go wait there's actually
no real risk here at all i'm not going
to be living under a bridge because i
change
lanes and go after the work that i
really want to do it does change
everything makes us uh gives us bigger
perspective gives us way more courage it
is a game changer piece solid foundation
the bill filters every financial piece
two words that don't go together with
like fouchy math
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at
debt free 825-5225 in the lobby of
ramsey solutions brittany is with us hi
brittany how are you i'm good excited to
be here well we're honored to have you
where do you live i live in findlay ohio
oh yeah very cool welcome to nashville
thank you and all the way down here to
do a debt-free screen yes sir how much
did you pay off 42 000. all right how
long did that take about 16 months 16
yes 16 months and your range of income
during that 16 months it was about 45
000 and it jumped up to 58 000. wow nice
jump what do you do for a living um i am
a shipping administrator
a what shipping shipping administrator i
do a lot of paperwork okay cool i think
i'm deaf today all right so what kind of
debt was your 42 000. it was all student
loans all right got rid of sallie mae
give her her eviction notice put the old
woman on the street way to go how long
you been out of school
uh about a year and a half okay so you
got out of school and decided to attack
this straight up
how did you connect up with us what made
up what made you believe that this was
doable so
it was about three years ago my sister
and mom
took financial peace university and so
they told me a little bit about you
um but i was just looking on youtube and
um
it was about a year and a half ago is
when i started but i um
that's when i got serious i started
watching your videos and
got serious and i'm like i'm just gonna
do this and
all right
yep very very cool well congratulations
so you come out of school and say all
right mom and sis did this it's worth it
i don't want this 42 000 hanging around
my neck i'm gonna knock it out yes you
went crazy girl you did in a short
period of time yeah so what caused your
income to jump up
um a lot of overtime
and i also did instacart uh grocery
deliveries on the side
was that profitable is it worth doing uh
yeah um only because i could do that
with my daughter
oh okay so um i would work my 50 55
hours a week and then
take her with me and do some grocery
deliveries okay so you've been you've
been hustling and grinding yes
way to go way to go that makes it
especially sweet when you're free then
it sure does yeah and you don't have to
take the ot and you don't have to take
the instacart and you're free yes yeah
that's cool wow so
uh besides all the crazy hours yeah
because you really worked hard and it's
a testament to you
what was one of the hardest things about
this journey of knocking it out um
probably
like i didn't go out to eat at all um
and enough time you're working
[Laughter]
um and no starbucks coffees um that was
probably my hardest thing
but i would like every two weeks i would
buy myself a coffee so i didn't
completely deprive myself oh no that's a
very interesting so
what would you say to other people about
that little bit of a treat every once in
a while i wouldn't call it a cheat but a
little treat what did that do for you um
it just i don't know it helped me i
think um
yeah she said hey it was worth it but
now i get back to sacrificing again yes
uh you work how much you need some
strong coffee i'm telling you i'm
telling you
it's almost like juice you're a machine
girl you got after it you are you are
hot man you're getting it so do you grow
up uh with a family that has that kind
of work ethic i mean what made you turn
it on like that because you turned it on
yeah i mean yeah i learned a lot from my
parents they're
they're pretty good workers um
but what helped me
i had i saved about 10 grand and i threw
all that towards it and i think that
that kind of took away a little bit of
it from the start
but then
let's see
um i forget what i was gonna say sorry
that's okay yeah that's fine so what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of that ass
um
definitely the budget
and um just sticking with the budget it
sounds simple but it's really it's
really that simple it's just the
self-discipline to follow it yeah you
just laid out the plan and then hustle
and grind and push the plan through as
fast as you can and then i could step
back and have a coffee
yeah exactly a coffee very good
expensive coffee so now that you're free
what do you want to do
i don't even know i haven't really even
thought about it um
i don't know there's just so much to do
and i want to help people so
um like the more money i make the more
people i can help and i think i don't
know yeah yeah that's true
that's true it's hard to help people
when you're broke that is it's a good
thing that's a good thing yeah it gives
you a tool to help people with that's
really about all it's good for actually
this thing called money but yeah so very
very well done how old is your daughter
she was seven all right did she come
with you she sure did all right we're
gonna get her in the debt-free scream
here what's her name her name is kira
kyra all right seven-year-old kara so
kara's been on a really uh this has been
a tough year for her because mom's been
gone a lot
yeah and she got to go on a lot of
instacart rides she sure did yeah didn't
hurt her either so
she's old enough that she will remember
the price mom paid to get rid of her
student loans and have a free life for
the two of you so very very well done
you're you're a noble lady i'm proud of
you you're a rock star you're a hero
very very cool stuff we got a copy of uh
the baby steps millionaire book which
comes out in january but you get an
early copy because you're here and i
know a guy so we're gonna hook you up
and because i think you're gonna be a
babysitter's millionaire i think she's
gonna be one pretty quick and to that
end i would like to give her a copy of
from paycheck to purpose so she can
really now that she's debt-free began to
figure out who are those people she
wants to help and how could she do it
make really good money in the process
and
we'll get that shovel even bigger for
you so we're going to give you that too
yeah we'll load you up with that and a
total money makeover book too so you're
going to leave here with so many books
you're not going to know what to do
and give away the total money makeover
book and read the other two that'll be
perfect because you know how to do this
stuff very very well done brittany thank
you all right brittany and cara from
toledo ohio 42 000. finley ohio 42 000
paid off in 16 months making
45-58 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two
one we're debt-free
love it
very very cool
well
that young lady can do anything oh no
stopping she's got a dad gum superman
cape
and uh
she's got the ability to step in and do
anything
uh and and just so unassuming about it
just it's you know non-plus it's just
what you do that's what i did this is
what you do yeah no big deal well you
see that beautiful little kira next to
her just you know kind of shining bright
and you see the the motivation for any
parent but certainly a single mama uh
what i love about brittany's story is a
lot of single moms that heard that story
and if you don't think you can do it
britney says otherwise making forty five
thousand okay i'm gonna take on ot and
instacart get it up to 58. 42. that's
thirteen thousand dollars of the forty
two ten went towards it they left 32
still and the overtime picked up and
then the tight budget and they did it
yeah i mean this is real it is those are
real numbers tough 16 months right no
question and kyra sat there and watched
mama do it i don't know if there's a
crater
she'll never she can't she can't lose
that it's part of her life now it's part
of her heritage yeah so she's a hero
that's just beautiful beautiful and well
well done very good stuff very good
stuff
all right julia from instagram says ken
i love my job but it doesn't pay enough
to get me out of debt do i keep the job
i love or start looking for something
else keep it for the moment while we
start looking for something else we're
going to replace that job pretty darn
quick but i don't want you to leave it
until we have something better to step
into because the reality is it's no
sense in you having any interruption and
income none at all certainly when we are
what about the part where she loves her
job
uh it doesn't matter she can love
another job that pays even more see
there's the see people think there's a
trade-off that if i love this job i'm
not allowed to ever not allowed to make
good money at something i love or that
i'll never love another one quite the
quite the opposite right so here's what
we do here's what we teach very simple
formula for julia for anybody else that
hears that question
um if you are doing work that you're
really good at that's your talent you're
doing work that you really love she's
identified that already and that work is
creating a result
that she connects to
that's how we know ding ding ding this
is also a job that i love i would add
one other element to that is make sure
it's a healthy culture good place where
the people value you that's how you know
no risk she can step right into another
job she loves it pays her way more
you don't have to leave a job you love
for a job you hate you could leave a job
you love for a job you love
[Music]
that's a false premise yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones of triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show anna is in
sacramento hi anna how are you
[Music]
ah my heart is beating
hey
you'll be okay we've never lost a
patient what's up
um so
i just wanted i don't know encouragement
or advice
so we moved here to sacramento area from
spokane washington about five years ago
and our babies got uh 3b
um but it seems like we finally have a
good down payment of 200k
but the prices have shot up
to where
you know if we buy a decent house our
it's not going to be 25 of our take-home
pay
and um
so we've been driving our kiddos to a
school about half an hour away from
where we live now because you know we
live in a bit of a cheaper part of town
uh we've been doing that for a couple of
years and i don't know it's just the gas
prices are going up everything is going
up and we're just kind of playing catch
up and trying to do the right thing and
i don't know if we should just bite the
bullet and buy a house super expensive
or like should we keep on saving like
what should we do
well uh
the reason that we have the guidelines
we teach in place and you're familiar
with all of them obviously
be out of debt have an emergency fund
before you buy that's why what you
described with baby step 3b where you're
saving for your down payment we don't
you to buy a house with debt because
it's going to give you trouble
um
the reason we've got all of these
guidelines like for instance that or 25
of your take-home pay is the max you
ought to have in payment um
you know is because we don't we want you
to win long term
and so let's just say you said okay
based on this situation um math doesn't
apply because i live in california
hahaha right and so i'm gonna go buy a
house it's 40 of my take-home pay
well you know what's gonna happen right
you're gonna struggle because you just
tightened your budget up so tight you
can't move you can't breathe you're
gonna be house poor
and you're gonna all of a sudden you're
not gonna have the money to save up to
buy the next car and you're gonna get
car debt and you're not gonna have the
money to do this and you're gonna end up
with debt on that you're not gonna have
the money to do that you end up with
debt on that and that's what happens
when people get house poor
and um you're gonna you're gonna cycle
right back in and end up being a normal
broke person broke person and you don't
want to be a normal broke person
right
so it's not like dave just made up these
nasty rules or something they're for you
yeah i'm just wondering should we go
ahead and buy a cheaper house and
continue the 30-minute commute even
though the gas price and it's like
almost so four something a gallon like
i'm just
i'm waiting for the prices of the houses
to go down because everybody's leaving
california but
i i thought they were going to too but
they're not
they may but it's going to be a while
longer um so you know there's not a a
hugely wrong answer here if you want to
rent for a couple more years and see
what this market shakes out a little bit
it could
there could be enough of an exodus to
actually affect the market
um it hasn't yet
yeah no
opposite way it's going up and um
real estate in general does not go down
sometimes it slows how much it goes up
but in general it doesn't go down
and so you know you want to rent a
little bit more and then make your
purchase or do you want to buy now and
ride the wave up with the values and
then make another move in three years
you can do that and because your house
that you're living in will increase in
value unless the market shakes out
i mean if you bought a house today
unless california real estate goes down
because of the exodus then you're going
to be okay you'll make some money on it
and you can move up later after you've
saved some more and at least you're
riding the at least you're in on the
ownership game right
probably what we would do
the gas price thing is irrelevant yeah
i'm just curious and where's that coming
from where's you keep mentioning gas
prices somebody else talking to you
about that
using that as a good excuse or is that
something that just really freaking you
out in the monthly budget
um a monthly budget it's just um so i
drive them 30 minutes to school and then
i drive 30 minutes back home and then at
the end of it like it's an hour
round
every time twice yeah twice i guess i
get some days a week yeah yeah yeah
can you can you rent it
can you rent closer to the school
affordably
not affordably no
it's it's crazy and if you bought what
would be the percentage of your income
on a 15-year fixed
overbought school
over by the school so ours
yeah so it would be 35-ish
30-35 our take-home is 12k
um if we bought a
livable house i mean on a 15 year 25 is
a guideline to keep people from doing 40
and 50. so it doesn't mean you can't do
27 you know or something like that and
so if you can
if you stretch it a little bit knowing
that your income is coming up if you
know your income is coming up i haven't
asked you about that but if your incomes
are
you know trending upward uh at a good
pace not just three percent a year
but um
they're there and the only thing we know
about gas prices is they're going to
change
i mean
two years ago they were half
and uh
you know and then they'll change again
and then they'll change again so
um
not the first time we've had five dollar
gas
well i've been on the air
yeah
you know i hear this and i i hear that i
hear the hour two hours a day
essentially is what we're talking about
and you know you education for your kids
you've you've been very intentional
about where they're going to school
obviously i think this is one of those
deals where just like the stories we
hear of people that are paying off debt
or people that lose tremendous amount of
weight you have to keep the finish line
at the top of your mind and save it a
little bit more right save a little bit
more sacrifice in a little bit in that
time it stinks the worst house in that
neighborhood yeah but soon you're not
going to have that commute and i think
you let that drive you but keep your eye
on the finish line if you buy the worst
house in that old in that other
neighborhood instead of just looking at
the average house in that other
neighborhood then you get over the close
to the school and you do it at 26 or 27
or something like that that's not the
end of the world the point is not the
exact percentage
it's not like 24.7 is the is the number
and if you go over that you're screwed
you know
it's not the point is don't have so much
house payment that you can't breathe
and have justified that because i live
in california or i need to be in this
certain neighborhood or i need to
do that and well you don't understand
you understand if you can't yeah i do
understand math works everywhere i do
understand
and so just don't rationalize your you
know yourself into a dead gum mess and
that if you avoid that you'll be okay
and because it's an emotional thing when
you're driving an hour each way and
you're dealing with your kids issues and
you're dealing with that it's all
emotion and if you're not careful every
time i get emotional and you know i i
make stupid decisions so um don't don't
do that
twyla is with us in minneapolis while
we're short on time ask your question
right fast
okay so thank you for taking my call i'm
a family nurse practitioner
and
i
have the opportunity to take some travel
rn positions that would be twice my
income
but i love my job i really could stay
here until i retire
so i'm just kind of in a predicament i'm
not sure if it's
worth doing it if i if i did
jump on the travel nurse train i could
have my debt paid off in seven months
versus right now i'm at about 15. all
right next question for me then is could
you come back into the practitioning
role if you took a season and you were
in the travel nurse role so let's say
you did it for a year year and a half
two years and then came back would that
be a pretty easy transition back
it would be easy to come back into the
family nurse practitioner role just
probably not like where i work right now
yeah i think you gotta weigh this i
think the you know you're gonna get out
of debt faster but what's the trade-off
and if you're only taking the travel
nurse job just to juice and you hate it
yeah then i probably wouldn't do it i'd
be i would be patient which is hard and
stay in the job you love knowing that
you are going to get out of here if you
instead or not hating it and you're
going
i love this idea it sounds like an
adventure i'm going to go do it for two
years and then i'm going to come back
and work it out and this and i'll be
debt-free and i will have had an
adventure and if you see it that way
like i want to travel europe after i
graduate from college before i take a
job you know i mean if you look at it
that way right then yeah go do it yeah
uh it's probably not something you're
signing up for for 20 years yeah
i think she could find something else
she loves as a practitioner i'd do it
get that emergency fund knocked out too
fast you mean come back come back later
yeah i'd do it but only if there's a
sense of adventure not a sense of dread
that's right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
open phones at 825-5225
joe is in san antonio hi joe how can we
help
how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm getting married to uh to a
girlfriend of five years this coming
spring good friend and uh we're both
both completely debt-free she's about to
graduate college and um awesome how old
are you guys
both 19. i'm turning 20 in a couple of
days wonderful
and um
and i just wanted to know if it would be
a good idea to gift her six thousand
dollars to fund her ira for this year no
before we're actually combining finances
and marriage no
no no
it will change
the tenor
and the tone
of your unmarried relationship
you're a guy and you're thinking in math
terms
i'm an old guy
who's been married 40 years and has done
a whole lot of stupid butt stuff
that i didn't know i was stupid when i
was doing it it affected the tenor and
the tone of my relationship and i've had
to go back and clean up a lot of it but
yeah no no no no no
to you it's just a math problem
to her it's a power play
okay
maybe i might be severe or melodramatic
in that
uh it could affect the way her dad feels
could affect the way her mom feels
it might change the way you
sit in a chair when you're discussing
wedding budgets
you see what i'm saying
i see what you're saying you've you've
departmentalized compartmental as this
is a simple mathematical thing over here
to the side which is a very smart
mathematical thing by the way you came
up with a really good idea but you did
not uh factor in all the negative
relational possible consequences and it
ain't worth it dude you're 19 years old
you got the rest of your freaking life
to get rich and you're going to be so
rich it's going to be unbelievable and
none of it will be because you
pre-funded your fiance before you were
married
retirement plan when you were 19 years
old that didn't cause you to be rich
what caused you to be rich is you're
smart enough to even ask this question
when you're this age yeah uh pretty
simple there's no upside at all just
wait well there's an upside it's math
yeah math upside's huge well yeah but
there's no relational upside down
relational downside so that mean to me
there's no upside so wait until you get
married then you fully funder once you
guys get rolling and yeah to their point
they're 19. he's gonna be 20. i mean my
goodness or he is 20. she's 19. so yeah
just stay out of it i love the i love
the question
you know i love that well i think it
shows it shows he's paying attention yes
god if i was 19 and i paid attention
where would that
i did pay attention but it wasn't a
smart to the right things that's right
gave a lot of attention to the wrong
thing
i was enthusiastically stupid
an enthusiastic ignoramus but yeah
that's uh yeah dude you're you're very
smart it's a very smart and intellectual
and good math question and it
mathematically it would be a beautiful
move uh but the offside is not worth it
and something happens and you got a
problem
so good question thank you for joining
us hey let's let me let me grow on that
just a little bit ken because uh we've
got a ton of folks young folks in our
audience who are uh uh pre-married
let's call them pre-married
they they hadn't gotten married yet
and uh when you pay someone's bills that
you're not married to and you're not
unified with
contractually in a covenant in a
spiritual relationship you change the
tenor
of that
the old joke is if you if you loan your
brother-in-law a hundred dollars and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it
that's the old because it changes when
you loan people money when you give
people money it changes
the the chemistry now the better the
person the more noble the intent the
less
obvious the change is
but it does change it and uh and i'm old
and i've done this a long time and so
i've seen all the negative things like
we had a guy one time he paid off a
whole bunch of his uh fiance's debt
and then they bought a house together
before they were married
and
and then
she died in a car wreck
before they were married
now he owns a house with his
fiance's mother
and
his fiance's mother the estate of his
fiancee owes him money wow for the debt
that he paid off
or he loses all that money either one
i mean it was a tragedy upon tragedy
upon tragedy it so
uh obviously the death in a car wreck
was an unspeakable tragedy
uh and dave you're talking about money
in the middle of something like that no
i'm just talking about the the in the
middle of an unspeakable tragedy we've
got more layers
to the problem rather than just the
tragedy yeah
and so yeah you don't you do not want to
be
owning a house with your mother-in-law
that was never your mother-in-law no
because you never got married yeah and
again all the intentions are good but
it's it's it's so important that you
keep everything separate until you get
into that married union and now it's we
and and just you're right it change you
know what it does it creates a little
bit of leverage and i think you're right
a mature person a healthy person won't
use that leverage intentionally
intentionally but boy the leverage is
there it absolutely is there i'm i'm
pretty
emotionally mature pretty especially
mature i've been doing this stuff a long
time but if i give ten thousand dollars
to something
it changes my you know and it was a
generous gift
and i still have and i don't have an
expectation of you know when i walk in
the room you bow down three times or
something like that i don't have
anything like that but then i but then
if they um
you know they
i i don't know slight you in a
conversation yeah
you're much more you're ten thousand
dollars worth are more offended that's
the truth it's exactly you cannot keep
that from happening because it's human
nature and i'm aware of it i teach it
i've written books about this stuff
but but then i find myself in that it's
not that i demand respect or i'm some
kind of arrogant butthole or something
like that that's not the point
that's not but but but you know
you know i've given x numbers of tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousand
dollars to this thing and and then you
go in there and they act like you're not
there
and hey that's pretty stupid but um but
but but you know from a just a
development standpoint sure but but
aside from that it's just human nature
to say
gosh
they didn't even say thank you yes
you know like i have a relative who um
if you don't send a thank you note
she'll call you
where's my thank you note oh
you know and i i guess
well she's old school right manners mrs
manners the books you know i mean you
should have manners
and say thank you
but that comes with the gift right
and so it's human nature
human nature it changes relationships
the transfer of money does
you can't keep it from happening the
borrower is slave to the lender
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
just a few days to christmas
it's hard to think about and it's crazy
it's like halloween was just here and
now christmas i mean it's really right
here you just got a minute did you get
something for me
yet yeah
he didn't see that one coming coming in
the uh
it's coming in your paycheck envelope
okay
i'm excited about that
it's coming with your company christmas
party
did you get me ken what'd you give me
well you know stacey stacy always gets
it yeah you know that to be true stacy
goes stacy and sharon might take care of
each other you and me or me and me
that's why they said she goes hey we
bought dave and sharing something it
ends up it's just for sharon
because stacey picked it out guys don't
think about stuff like that
i love it well it doesn't have to be
that hard you could give financial peace
university not to ken or me we've had it
but um
if you want to plan for your money and
you want some confidence so that
christmas doesn't sneak up on you next
year by the way they don't move it um
you can learn a step-by-step plan on how
to get out of debt how to save money how
to build wealth how to be outrageously
generous and then you have money to buy
in a christmas gift yeah if you were
that way see
and um the average family going through
this class saves twenty seven hundred
dollars and pays off five thousand three
hundred dollars that's an eight thousand
dollar changing position in the first 90
days that's an average wow that's
tremendous a good rate of return
right now financial peace university is
available as a part of your ramsey plus
membership you do not have to go to a
live go through a stressed out christmas
like this well you don't have to live
like this
make 2022 the year you finally start
winning with money or give the financial
peace universities a gift just ramsey
solutions dot com slash fpu that's
ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu jessica is in phoenix hi jessica
welcome to the ramsey show
hi hi what's up hello
um so my husband and i are trying to
build a house
we figure it will cost about
155 000.
we have 50 000
in the bank
have the opportunity to borrow about 70
000 from my family
and so my question is
i know you don't like family debt so i'm
wondering
if that's the way to go
no don't like family debt
um
okay yeah uh and the reason is what we
were just talking about before the break
um that it's right you know it changes
the relationship it changes everything
odd that your call would come right
after that but uh almost like you had to
sit there and listen to that right but
the uh uh
but yeah
so what would be wrong with just going
and getting a construction loan for the
hundred thousand
from my understanding well a couple
problems one i understand they're pretty
high uh
rates and then two we're going to build
it ourselves and i don't think anyone
will lend to us because we are not
you're going to struggle with that
that's true you'd have to get a general
contractor to come alongside you and you
have to have an approved set of plans
but you probably ought to have that
anyway the contractor doesn't have to
make a big fee
they could just be the supervising
contractor and that'll help you get the
construction loan
besides that you don't have enough if
you only borrow 70 from your parents and
that means they don't have enough to be
loaning you money
because they don't have enough to do
this deal
not the whole thing you're taking their
last dime
stress all over it stress stress stress
stress stress stress everywhere here so
no i would go to the local bank and
you're gonna you're gonna be required to
get uh pre-approved for a mortgage for
the final loan amount when it's
completed which it sounds like it'll be
100 000 or so
and
that bank might approve you for the
final for the permanent mortgage
and the other and then you're going to
have to convince them with the aid of a
supervising contractor and here's a
qualified set of plans you can't just go
in with stuff drawn up on the back of a
paper bag no we've got we've got plans
already okay you got full on set of
plans and you bid them out with subs and
you show that you know what you're doing
and you show that the contractor is
overseeing this and you can get that you
can get that construction line and that
that way your family's not stressed out
okay
i don't know if i don't know if a
contractor would take that on because
we don't plan to step out for any of it
i didn't say that
so the contractor has to supervise
and you will have to get approvals for
codes
on electrical right yeah building times
you got to sub that out or you're not
going to get you're not going to get
code approval because you're not
licensed plumbers
well you don't have to have you have to
just have to have it inspected and that
has to pass the inspection you don't
have to
so as long as it passes inspection you
have to have certain inspections as the
process goes along okay
so then the contractor wouldn't take a
uh you can find a general contractor
they're not everywhere because
everybody's busy right now but you can
find somebody with a gc license who you
pay a flat fee just to put their name on
this as the supervising contractor
okay and if you have the knowledge to
actually build a house you probably have
the knowledge to find that gc
okay
and i just pay them 2 000 bucks to be
your gc and they don't do anything
except put their name on it
but they go with you to the bank they
approve they say you know i'm
supervising this and if they want to
walk over there as a matter of integrity
and check it three times but you need to
have a plan for building this house in
very short order too you're not don't
enter into something takes five years to
build that's not what you're talking
about right
no how fast you're gonna get this thing
out of the ground get it finished
i think a year and a half once we step
once we break ground
okay so when does he when is he gonna be
working at his job
my husband
going he build it
you're going to build
the yeah the kind of construction we're
doing is something that i can do you're
doing the plumbing you're doing the
electrical you're putting on the roof
yep
uh we have a brother-in-law that's going
to help us with the electrical um my
husband will have to help when we do the
roof but
nearly everything else
okay so you've got construction
experience
no
okay
and you're gonna plumb this house
yep
what off a youtube video i don't
understand
yeah pretty much
i'm pretty handy
yeah but there's a difference between
being handy and constructing a house
this could turn into a four and a half
year build at this rate
um i i admire your confidence and your
sense of adventure but everything you're
saying is scaring the crap out of me
yeah um
this is scary so you do whatever you
wanna do you're a grown-up girl
um but um but this sounds like a project
that you're gonna call me up in 10 years
ago i'm still screwing with this thing
um because the youtube video didn't tell
me about this and um
there's a lot this is fraught with
danger
so
definitely don't use family money
definitely
because you're pulling them into your
dream that may be a nightmare
definitely
don't use family money that that seals
the deal for me
um
in translation
because i care about you and i'm just
going to tell you the truth um
i i think you're biting off more than
you know how to chew
and i i built many houses i own several
hundred million dollars worth of real
estate the building we're sitting in
uh right now the building complex is
four hundred thousand square feet
um and uh you know somewhere around 200
million dollars worth of buildings just
in this one project and so it's not like
i'm not i
don't have any clue what i'm talking
about here and let me tell you how much
of the plumbing i did none
okay none
uh and it's not because i'm some stupid
rich guy is but i i you know and i walk
the property i walk the property we're
building on the other day right now i'm
just going up there looking at the
footings going in on a thing and so i
grew up in this business and
you know you're scaring me for you
you're not gonna affect me but you're
scaring me for you
it um and everybody's listening is going
uh-huh
so you be careful jessica be careful
um i'm not trying to tell you not live
your dream i just don't want your dreams
to be a nightmare
this is harder than it looks so um
wow and way more expensive it's not just
the execution piece you know it's the
expense it is the real estate building a
house is a little bit like business
there's three rules you know
it's gonna take twice as long as you
thought it's gonna cost twice as much
you thought and you're not the exception
those are the three rules it's not quite
that bad with real estate but
you know it does take longer than you
thought especially in this world oh
it does cost more than you thought and
it is more difficult than you thought
and you're not the exception
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right welcome back to the ramsey
show i'm ken coleman
and uh we are here today dave ramsey uh
with me in studio and i look across in
the lobby and what do i see a beautiful
couple on the debt free stage
andrew and alexis joining us how are you
we're great how are you yeah well i'm
telling you i'm having a blast so tell
us where you're from we are from valonia
arkansas all right valonia arkansas all
the way here to do a debt free screening
yes yeah all right tell us the details
how much did you pay off a hundred and
one thousand dollars and 88 cents okay
and how long did that take about 16
months
and what was your range of income during
that time
we started the end of 2019 and i think
we made probably a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in 2019 but for 2020 we
made around 167 000.
so the pandemic was good to you it was
very good to us yeah at least
financially yes okay what do you all do
for a living i am a registered nurse
supervisor for the state of arkansas
this is where you went nuts yeah and i
own a
cab service in conway okay all right
good yeah both very busy what kind of
debt was the 101 thousand surprisingly
none of it was student loans um it was
two credit cards
two vehicles and a four wheeler
y'all were normal we were very very
normal how long you been married uh
five years
i think five years five years
she says with a question
i don't know
i'm just here i'm sure because you told
me to be here right
that's fun all right and so uh but
something happened two years ago
well
um andrew kept coming home with
spreadsheets telling me that i was
spending all of our money so we had to
figure something out
okay andrew talk about this tell me
what's going on here well she's got a
shopping problem
not anymore no not anymore
um
i guess she just got tired of those
spreadsheets and she started listening
to you and then she put me onto you oh
and uh i think we we were listening to
your tony
or total money makeover when we were
going up to our cabin
and uh we just listened to it and it was
it hit you right in the mouth actually
or hit me in the mouth
for sure okay
so alexis so he's coming home with
spreadsheets but you found us correct
what tell me about this
i just was tired of feeling guilty and
tired of getting talked to so
i was like i gotta figure something out
you know so maybe i can have some
spending money because we were drowning
in payments
so
i found you guys on a spotify from you
know your podcast and started listening
and then i bought an audiobook version
of the total money makeover okay and
that's the cabin ride yes and i'll punch
you in the mouth as you said correct
yeah i got to know dave before we go any
further so andrew you're bringing all
these spreadsheets was there a lot of
tension here or were you just kind of
passive about it real gentle or were you
kind of intense i mean i need to know i
mean it kind of went both ways uh
there's certain times to be passive
about it and there's times that you just
got to put your foot down and like hey
this is what's going on
you know
living
paycheck to paychecks is not my way of
living i i didn't
i didn't grow up with a whole lot of
money so i always wanted something more
and that was a way of trying to doing it
and we make too much money be this broke
correct yeah you both said that on the
ride to the cabin okay so that's the
opportunity you're listening to the
audio book and that's the first time you
actually both go we're going to work on
this yeah correct okay and then you came
home and did a budget or what'd you do
yes she did most of the work
actually um i used every dollar the
every dollar app and that's where we
started and we made a decision that you
know
we keep our thousand dollars for our uh
emergency fund in in the bank and that's
our cut off and at the end of our
paycheck whatever was left between the
balance and the thousand dollars we just
that's what i put on our credit card or
that's what i put on our auto loan
working the debt snowball correct yeah
cut up the credit cards yeah well we did
delete a whole lot of debt when we got
rid of our two vehicles yeah we did sell
our cars oh you sold both of them yes
whoa
what did they sell for
well um i had an escalade and he had a
3500 gmc dually
that one hurt
that one hurt he got a
2015 tundra i think for cash and
i did i did finance my camry but for
less money than what we had originally
owed and it was more manageable and it
gave us more money to work with
but
that loan's gone now it paid off too yes
so wow way to go you guys so you move
down in car substantially both of you
and uh get on a budget and go crazy and
here you are was it worth it yes yes 100
quick answer that's cool yeah they
couldn't wait to answer that yeah yeah
so you would do it again and know you
won't go back in debt correct yes never
never again never again yeah very good
all right so when people look at you
guys and go you lost your dad gum mine
you saw these two great cars your
friends probably thought you lost your
ever loving your mother thinks you need
counseling
i mean you got people thinking you're
crazy but you didn't care well my mom's
actually a financial advisor for edward
jones
so she she was on board with the whole
deal she she thought it was great i was
making that up i didn't know yeah
no um
they were our family was really
supportive um our friends do think we're
a little bit crazy and
whenever we would say no you know to go
and to eat dinner here go do this or go
on vacation but i think
most of them probably see the benefit
now yeah yeah so now they turn around
they ask you how did you do that you
paid off 101 000 in 16 months how'd you
do that what do you tell them the key is
well for us um it was originally going
to take us probably closer to three
years
but whenever corona hit
we were uncertain of what would happen
with his business it was either we were
going to get a payroll protection loan
or we were probably going to fold and so
andrew quit paying himself and went and
got another job so he was working a
full-time job as well as owning his
business and running it usually at night
time and then for me being a nurse you
know there were plenty of extra shifts
to pick up
um and then i also sold some other
things and
um so we made up the difference in the
income that way but
where there's a will there's a way yeah
there's an extra job right yeah yeah
that's what it is and then you you know
the other thing with you guys that i
think stands out and we need to give it
a word and say it out loud is um
one of your keys to getting out of debt
was contentment
you you were content with lesser car
correct and both of you took a sizable
dropping car
in terms of not just money but in terms
of the you know this massive awesome
escalade you know camry right and you
get rid of the cool truck and you know
in your world oh my gosh it's awful and
uh but but you were saying i want that
more than i want i want to be out of
debt more than i want that thing yes
right and i think a lot of it is that
those things are just things and
without social media or things like that
who cares if you have the escalator who
cares if you have the 3 500 you're doing
that for show and for what just for
people to say oh they have that but
really you don't the bank has that
that's the pin in the balloon there you
go that's that's that's awesome drop
right there
unbelievable story good really
incredible
wow wow so real quick we don't have much
time when we get you to scream
what do you say is the key to folks if
you said there's one thing we did that
we can transfer to others to win this
battle
um budget and be on the same page if
you're married yeah you've got to work
as a team if you don't work as a team
it's not going to work yeah good deal
well we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story you're gonna be
one it comes out january the 11th but uh
we have an early uh edition for you guys
because you made the trip over here and
hand it to you here in just a few
minutes and a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to friends
and um maybe some of them will be asking
about it you never know way to go you
guys i'm proud of you your heroes your
heroes you're amazing andrew and alexis
little rock arkansas 101 000 paid off in
16 months making 130 to 167.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
screen you ready three two
one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
there it is
i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 4 18
19 the path of the just is like the
shining sun
that shines ever brighter into the
perfect day the way of the wicked is
like darkness they do not know what
makes them stumble
winston churchill said we make a living
by what we get we make a life
by what we
give
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jack is with us
in
high point north carolina hi jack
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and ken um just want to say
dave ramsey thank you um you changed my
life and and changing my legacy of my
family because of you well thank you um
so
kind of two points i'm in a position
right now where i've got some paid off
real estate um i still have debt
we started out almost 10 years ago
gonzale intense
but ran into some situations where
taking care of my parents and
mother-in-law
we
bought their houses we'd been paying for
their houses
we had about
120 000 worth of debt 80 or 80 in credit
cards
and we've been killing it my wife and i
we worked really hard um we're not in
that fast get out of debt plan we've
been just just working at it over the
years and so
i'm at a point now where i've only got
probably
maybe
uh around 14 in consumer debt of one
that one type of another we've got about
a 1.4 million
uh worth of assets and about 960 000
net worth
so i see the light we see the light at
the end of the tunnel um and it's been
an incredible journey so we've still got
a ways to go
but what i've run into
is
the property that's paid off as a rental
and it's producing the income that we
use to help pay for one of our parents
home
and i don't want to lose that um
so i also want to protect it
so i'm in a position where
i want to put it in a trust so i can
leave it to my family my kids um and
i've looked at all these different
trusts out there revocable irrevocable
kind of lost why does it need to be in
the trust where to put it why does it
need to be untrusted
okay so that's where i need some
guidance so i don't want them to get a
death in inheritance tax when i leave it
to him and i don't want him to get um
taxed to death with it so i'm kind of
not looking for direction so how much is
probate tax in north carolina do you
know
it's probably going to be somewhere
around a million but we'll be leaving
that you know i'm anticipating
no no no no no no no no no no no
you misunderstood me okay you do not
have any federal
estate tax
problems you have you have an 11.7
million dollar exemption
for federal okay so you don't have a
federal estate tax problem the only
estate taxes you might have would be
probate tax for the state of north
carolina which i don't know what that is
off the top of my head google it oh
there we go um
and uh but uh uh
because i i mean a lot of states are
like three percent or something
so it might be it might be 30 000 bucks
you don't you don't have an estate tax
problem i don't think unless north
carolina's got some outrageous weird
estate thing going on which would shock
me in north carolina
but um
uh all this property is in north
carolina right
yes sir okay
let's see here
the fee for estates in excess of ten
thousand dollars is forty dollars plus
four dollars per
thousand so it's four percent yeah
okay so that's nothing so i was about i
was about right you have a four percent
tax on a million
dollars would be 40 grand
all right so as focusing on
eventually leaving that to my kids
what would be some words of wisdom of
what i might should
focus on as far as the
what i have how old are you
uh 48
what's 45
okay um i mean you can just leave it to
them in a will straight up and then they
would become the owners of it it's that
simple they're going to pay a 40 000
fee in this now you can avoid that
if you put this into
uh into a living trust
okay uh the portion that you put in the
living trust will pass outside of
probate and save you four percent
a living trust will typically cost you
about thirty five hundred dollars in
legal fees to put in place
i'm 61 i do not have a living trust
and a lot more and here's why i don't
have one here's why i don't have one at
61.
the items that you move into the living
trust
after you pay the legal fees to form the
thing
are operated by the trust then
and i don't want to have to screw around
to
go get the trustee to sign something if
i want to sell something that i own
and if i want to operate something that
i own if i want to buy insurance on
something that i own if i want to
everything you do you have to screw
around with a trust on it
and from an operations standpoint it's a
nightmare
and it's why a lot of people don't do it
but uh but it will save you forty
thousand dollars when you die
uh in my world it ain't worth it uh 40
000 it's worth it to operate the thing
and be able to not mess with it so if i
were in your shoes personally it's what
i've done i don't have a living trust um
i i have you know i have stuff in llcs i
don't own anything anymore everything's
in an llc or a corporation of some kind
but all of that is left in our estate
plan
into
a through through the vehicle of a will
and there are some trusts formed upon my
death that are estate planning because i
have a i have an estate in excess of
11.7 million so i've got a federal
estate tax problem that's a different
set of issues
but um in your case dude i just have a
will
thanks ken quick on the google yeah see
dave that's sometimes that's just all
you know your role folks
okay we get into this kind of complex
finances folks there's no it's not who i
am i'm the purpose and bigger paycheck
uh but i can google things for you dave
and see you got to know your role google
ken
ken google i'll give him a new name i do
want to point out these folks that it
was a reputable site so that was that
wasn't off of wikipedia i didn't just
hand dave i looked at it long enough to
know that i'm not han and dave wikipedia
all right nothing against that well
there you go well it did come through
google so i mean you know
this is so folks anytime you want an
answer to a question call us we'll
google it for you
here's what it really means if dave
can't answer it ken can via google
that's right i'm dave's research
assistant when necessary
michelle is in boston hey michelle
what's up
hey how are you thank you for taking my
call today sure my question has to do we
have phase out this year of being able
to put money into a roth ira for our
retirement and we get no tax benefit of
doing a traditional ira so what would be
your recommendation well this year is
the last year you can do what's called a
back door roth the binding
administration has closed the door after
this year but for this year you can do a
backdoor roth
and the back door works like this after
the first year just open a an after tax
traditional ira and instantaneously
convert it to a roth
and you can put um six thousand bucks in
that
you know and uh i did it last year sure
and i do them every year we'll do it
this year it'll be our last year that we
get to do that
after that you've got to invest you max
out any kind of anything you've got
available and it sounds like you already
have
and you would just invest in things that
are capital gains
growth
now let me explain what that means okay
um okay the easiest one the easiest
example is real estate but you don't
have to do real estate so if you buy a
house as a an investment
for two hundred thousand dollars and it
goes up to three hundred 000 in value
you do not pay taxes on that 100 000
increase until you sell the house
right
right the value increase you don't pay
taxes until you sell it same's true with
stock if you buy stock and hold it if it
goes up in value you don't pay taxes on
the the capital gains growth until you
sell it and when you do sell it it's
taxed only at your capital gains rate
not an ordinary income rate so like a
traditional like an annuity or something
like that it's going to be taxed at
ordinary income but if you sell a stock
or a house or a piece of land or
whatever you're going to be taxed to 15
unless you make over 400k and then
you'll be packed extra 20
on capital gains rate and so you buy
things that'll hold like that and an
example of an easy thing to do like that
is called a low
turnover mutual fund write that down a
low turnover mutual fund and that's an
index fund like a for like a s p 500 is
an example of that you can put small
amounts of money in there it'll grow and
won't pay taxes on it until you get
there ken thanks for your assistance
today yeah always there for you dave
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you